it's been 19 years since the original
lord of the rings trilogy ended and i'm
out here feeling like today's
birthday so when amazon was like we're
gonna make the world's most expensive
show and set it in middle earth i was
all for it but before we take a deep
dive into the episode there are a few
things you should know the story is
based mainly off the appendices from the
lord of the rings so while the show may
include some characters we'll recognize
the story will largely be completely
original other than the forging of the
rings of power and what happened to them
there won't be any major spoilers in
this video because there's no source
material to spoil from so let's venture
back to middle earth dig through all the
lore and see if the show is worth
watching or throwing into the fires of
mount doom episode 1 is titled shadow of
the past named after my ex-girlfriend
and while it may seem like we're
somewhere in middle-earth we're actually
across the great sea on the continent of
amman also known as the blessed realm
this is where frodo bilbo elrond and
galadriel set off at the end of return
of the king only immortals and ring
bearers were allowed to live there here
we meet young galadriel elves as we know
can live thousands of years in fact
galadriel is 8
374 years old in return of the king she
looks pretty damn good for her age
rewinding several thousand years we see
her bullied as a kid with the show
already painting her as strong-willed
and independent a girl who isn't afraid
to back down from a fight tolkien
describes galadriel as the greatest of
the noldor she was strong a body mind
and will a match for both the lore
masters and the athletes of the eldar in
the days of their youth galatrial's
sailboat becomes a teachable moment for
her elder brother finrod he remarks that
the difference between a stone and a
sailboat is that although both are
pulled toward the darkness of the sea
below the sailboat's gaze remains upward
toward the light but galadriel is smart
stating that sometimes it's difficult to
tell what is up and what is down like
when sunlight reflects off the water's
surface if that happens how do you
really know which way is up and which
way is down finrod whispers something
into galadriel's ear something we don't
actually hear until the end of the
episode where galatrial makes the
decision to abandon ship and forego her
journey to the blessed realm a journey
which no elf has ever turned down
finrod's answer to her question is this
sometimes we cannot know
[Music]
until we have touched the darkness only
until galadriel has taken that leap of
faith can she know if her path is
leading toward or away from darkness
finnrod had a profound impact on
galadriel's upbringing in valinor we see
a shot of the city here along with these
two large trees tilparian and lorelin
both being a source of light for the
elves these trees would later be
destroyed by angolian the giant spider
creature and mother of shelob from lord
of the rings this occurred at the hands
of the first dark lord melkor also known
by a cindara named morgoth think of
morgoth like the predecessor to sauron
so this huge war raged between the elves
and morgoth who controlled the orcs many
of the elves went eastward from valinor
including galadriel to the continent of
middle earth this war lasted centuries
and the toll it took on the elves was
catastrophic morgoth was eventually
defeated and his role taken over by the
dark lord sauron finrod vowed to take
out sauron and destroy him but was
killed in the process his body branded
with this trident-like symbol we'll
later see it etched on soron's anvil and
on the sword theo uncovers galadriel
takes her brother's dagger a physical
representation of her taking on his vow
to destroy the dark lord but centuries
of hunting sauron prove fruitless the
guy has seemingly disappeared and along
with him the elves will to search for
him galadriel leads the last remaining
team of warriors to the northernmost
reaches of flordweighth the northern
wastes there they uncover an old sauron
stronghold it's never mentioned whether
this is karn doom one of the
northernmost fortresses or a different
stronghold entirely this place was where
the orcs gathered after sauron's defeat
but an orc hasn't been seen in years
galadriel remarks that this place is so
evil that their torches give off no
warmth here they find these mummified
orcs who are meddling with powers of the
unseen world all things in arda that
being the entire world are either in one
of two worlds the scene or unseen the
unseen also known as the wraith world is
a place where objects and creatures of
the spirit world reside those who put on
the ring for example could see this
unseen world when wearing it sauron
seems to have been using this forge for
some dark sorcery considering sauron was
the one who forged the one ring of power
perhaps this was part of some precursor
to that galadriel has pushed her team to
the limit and after an attack by a frost
troll dwindles their numbers even
further she is essentially mutinied
against they will be returning home
whether she likes it or not shifting
south we find ourselves in rovanian
territory following two hunters they've
stumbled into harfoot territory which
are one of three breeds of what we now
know to be hobbits at this time the
shire was yet to be colonized so you had
these harfoots stores and fallow hides
migrating across middle-earth in what
was known as the wandering days among
them is saddock burrows a character
created specifically for the show who
appears to be somewhat of a shaman
reading the stars and consulting his big
book of prophecy in it we'll see an
image of one of those antlered hunters
followed by two beasts we'll end up
seeing one of these beasts later on so
it seems that whatever is in this book
has already been prophesized we also get
a look at eleanor nori brandyfoot who
appears to be one of the main characters
in the harfoot storyline she leads a
group of kids berry picking in
preparation for the annual harvest fest
it's here their picking is cut short
when they uncover one of the beasts
tracks in linden the elvish capital home
to king gilgalad we meet another
memorable lotr character elrond the same
elf who set forth the fellowship from
rivendell in the lord of the rings at
this time however he is herald to the
king preparing his speeches and acting
like his right-hand man believe it or
not king gilgalad can be seen briefly
alongside elrond at the battle of the
last alliance of elves and men he's also
seen as one of the three bearers of the
elven rings alongside galadriel and
kierdin elrond prepares a speech his
king is to give to galadriel and her
team on their successful mission ruling
out once and for all that sauron is no
more something galadriel does not
believe galadriel and elrond are old
friends and later elrond will go on to
marry galadriel's daughter calebrian the
two french remark on a mural of the
crossover a giant white light beckoning
a ship toward it it foreshadows
galadriel's trip there at the end of the
episode one which she'll deny galadriel
warns elrond that sauron has escaped and
is still out there yet she brings no
definitive proof of her claim she wants
elrond to ask the king to give her a
fresh company so she may venture out in
search once more but elrond is quick to
remind her that the king won't be so
receptive of this and that they should
hold off until after the ceremony of her
accomplishments this is because elrond
knows galadriel and her men are to be
given the great honor of being escorted
to the grey havens to rest for all
eternity in the blessed realm although
lacking of any significant plot
development this scene with nori shows
that she dreams of a world beyond her
own which likely foreshadows a large
journey for her in the future one which
may be tied to the mysterious meteor man
will meet at the end of the episode more
on that in a bit as the king honors
galadriel he exclaims they have quote
proven beyond any doubt that their days
of war are over rather than refute the
king during this most auspicious
occasion galadriel bites her tongue and
accepts the king's offer that night
however as the elves celebrate with
fireworks galadriel is not among them
she would rather be at the carved
memorial of her brother finrod she still
holds on to his dagger a reminder of the
vow she made to hunt sauron galadriel
tells elrond that she is compelled to
defeat the dark lord even if she has to
do so by herself but it's elrond who
offers a voice of reason even if sauron
is still out there how many more orcs
will she need to kill to appease her
nothing will bring back her brother and
only the blessed realm can heal that
which is broken within her he tries to
appease her by saying that he will take
up the mantle and fight evil should even
a whisper of it be heard in the
southlands in the small town of
tiraharad we find our third major
storyline of the episode which follows
arandir he's yet another character
created for the show an elf of the watch
wardens whose job is to keep tabs on the
local men who centuries ago were aligned
with morgoth erandir is kept in the loop
of the coming and goings about town by
local bar keep wardreg but not all the
locals are as keen to help their elven
overlords as we'll find out later
there's a general distrust of men among
the elves watchword in reviewian says of
them kept watch over the men and women
of tiharat not because of what their
ancestors once did but because of who
they still are erandir is a bit
different however he's fallen in love
with a human healer named bronwyn
something that is deeply frowned upon by
both human and elf kind and bonus points
if you saw him solving this dude's game
just by looking at the board for a mere
second bronwyn gets erendier some sweet
sweet seeds because nothing says love
more than seeds and erendier's partner
says this whole thing is bad news in
fact up until this point there have only
been two attempted pairings of humid and
elf and both ended in tragedy the most
well-known pairing you may remember is
that of king aragorn and arwen at the
end of return of the king but that
doesn't happen until the third age
thousands of years in the future
erendier's partner asks if these
pairings are so unsuccessful why does he
persist it's pretty clear the answer is
love but he's interrupted by the news
that all far outposts are to be
disbanded if there is no more evil
threat as the king declared then there's
no more need for these outposts and
after 79 years aaron dear is to return
home with accolades for his service
erendir sneaks away from his people to
visit bronwyn but their meeting is cut
short by a cow herder looking for
bronwyn his cow ventured off to
neighboring horden and seems to be
milking out this black goo this is now
the second odd event that has taken
place around town the first we heard at
the tavern where a farmer's crops had
been poisoned so something seems to be
going on here bronwyn decides to go with
erendier to investigate horden while her
son theo and his friend check out a
stashed artifact in a neighbor's barn
it's a broken blade with the mark of
sauron on it in fact for a brief moment
we can see the flaming mark's reflection
on theo's eyes at this point we really
don't know what this sword symbolizes
was it forged in that frozen fortress
does it have any hidden powers it
certainly has some sort of effect over
theo and perhaps one of the reasons it
was stashed here was because the people
of tiraharad had once been followers of
morgoth i'm really interested to see
what this discovery might lead to elrond
senses that galadriel has left his sight
king gilgalad confides in elrond that
this shadow galadriel spoke of still
exists but what elrond did was right for
both her and middle earth the king then
introduces him to a major figure in
ring's lore kelebrimbor he will be the
man who forges the rings of power and it
seems the king wants elrond to help him
in this project as the approach horden
bronwyn tells aerendir that she was born
there they are good people there however
we know that's just buttering us up for
the entire town to be burnt to the
ground as galadriel and her company
approach valinor we get a better idea of
what would have happened to frodo and
bilbo on their journey a wash of
intoxicating light takes over just as
elrond predicted but this light also
reminds galadriel of her brother and
consequently the vow she made to him at
the last moment she leaps from the
sailboat the same thing she made as a
child and jumps into the sea the ship
sails into the light leaving her in the
vast darkness of the ocean a throwback
to her brother saying sometimes we
cannot know which way is up or down
until we have touched the darkness but
the episode ends on an ever more ominous
note an asteroid from the sky barrels
down near the har foots of rovanian it's
nori who makes the discovery but it's no
asteroid
it's a man is it just a coincidence that
as a man seemingly falls from the sky
that a leaf all the way over in linden
is seen to die by this black rot and i
wonder if this rot is similar to the
blackness which came from the cow in the
credits this man is simply billed as the
stranger is it just me or does it seem
too obvious that this is sauron i think
the stronger writing choice here is that
if all this is a red herring and the
stranger is either someone completely
new or someone even more beloved than
galadriel and elrond that person being
gandalf it's totally possible it could
be him this person survived a fiery
crash just like gandalf did while
fighting the balrog in the minds of
moria gandalf is also extremely old he
was made by a louvitar or the omnipotent
creator before time even began so it's a
possibility alas will have to wait for
more episodes to shed light on this
mystery i'm hoping to come out with an
episode 2 breakdown as soon as possible
so be sure to like subscribe and comment
and keep a look out for that thanks for
watching everyone for more bad takes you
can follow me on twitter and instagram
at think story yt until next time
hundred remember eleventh birthday